For the grace of God offers salvation to
all people teaching us to live Godly
lives.
Jesus gave himself for us to redeem us and
to purify for himself a people
that are his very own.
Father we come to you humbly today.
What is we?
As we rush through life so much. We never slow
down and
and just rest in you and
deal with
our own hearts
So God, we want to start this time.
Thanking you.
this is not something that we're
we're coming to check a box or fill out
our Sunday with some activity. It's
it's because you are already here and we are coming to meet with
you.
We don't have to invite you here. We don't have to give you permission.
But God starts with us.
in our own hearts
bringing us to where you want us to be God break
down walls if there's something that we are.
Holding so tightly to God break
it down that we could see you today and be good soil in
our own Hearts to receive what you have for us.
God you've been stirring this.
For a while. I thank you for that. I thank
you for this time today.
Do your work?
And we give this to you. I pray every one of us in this room.
Anyone watching would give this moment to you
and say yours.
God what a gift. It's been already we pray now
as we move forward we see you for
who you are.
in Jesus name
I know it. It actually is Super Bowl Sunday today,
but it certainly feels like it to me in
here as well.
Like I pray there's been this stirring in my soul
all week.
For what? He's
Doing I'm seeing it happen all over. I
don't know if you've heard anything about what's happening at Asbury in Kentucky, but
The season back in the 70s of the Jesus
movement started from Asbury with the weeks long
Revival Awakening session. It's happening again.
It's the movie comes out about that one. It's happening even
right now.
And then we saw baptisms today and
last week and we see.
last Sunday just the taste of God's glory and
many ways and
then we come to this passage today. Like one of
the highest peaks of the entire Bible is right what we're gonna study today
just pure gospel pure good news, and then how we
are to respond to it. Like I I am
it's been just geared up all week for this.
For what God wants to do and so if you're not there already turn
with me to Titus Chapter 2 will be in
verses 11 through 15 today.
No, true movement of God happens apart from
his word. And so we stay tightly to that as we'll say again
later, but Titus 2 11 through 15.
We're in a sermon series through the book of Titus called his very own
where we're looking at the church being his and
so we ordered accordingly.
But then also us individually.
or his
so we should order our lives accordingly.
like that
So we're going to start this a little bit out of order
today tied us to verse 15 first. You'll
see why.
Remember Paul put Titus here on Crete and Titus
in a tough spot.
There and doing Ministry and so Paul speaks
directly to Titus in verse 15 says declare these
things.
Exhort and rebuke with all authority. Let no one disregard
you.
So what things is he saying to Titus to do
this with? Well, it is all of chapter 2 what he
just said in verse 1 this lifestyle that Accords
with sound Doctrine it matches what God says, you
should live like teach that boldly try
to stand confidently on the
fact that any rebuke or exhortation or truth
claim Titus. You can know that that's
come and directly from God.
Listen, that's the same thing today.
See any Authority that I have to stand up here and
say anything about anything any any Authority
or CG leader has to say what they're
saying or any Authority or Bible study teacher has to say what
they're saying. It comes from the word of God.
It's the only place this truly we can't
make up stuff and have any Authority. This is where we land and
so must be anchored to
God's word to have any sense of authority.
It's from God and here's why.
Here's why we cannot get distracted away
from the pure gospel.
Because it's not any idea that I or anyone else
can come up with that change is everything. It's actually
God's grace that changes everything.
That's that's the main point of this whole thing today.
That God's grace is the foundation God's grace
is what changes everything. It's not my ideas or
anybody else's ideas. It's God in his grace.
It's actually what we see start this verse 11.
Verse 11 starts with the word four f-o-r and
that word means because it links
back to what he just said remember in verses 1 through 10. Here's
how you're supposed to live. Men women Bond servants Titus.
Here's how you should live verse 11
starts with because
here's what he's about to say in other words. What he's about to
say is the reason and the way we're even
able to do what he just said to do.
So this word links us to what he says next. What does
he say for the grace of God has appeared?
Live like this because God's grace
showed up.
Now, let's be clear that Grace is not
merely an idea.
That Grace is a person.
Because John 1 says that Jesus the
word became flesh dwelt Among
Us full of grace and truth.
So it wasn't just the idea of Grace showed up. It was
Jesus showed up and him in Grace gave
them power to change.
And so again God's grace changes everything but it's not just Grace, it's
Jesus. He does the work he changes everything.
But before we go any further, we need to define grace because we all
need to be on the same page here because there's a whole lot of definitions and
understandings of Grace. What does grace actually
mean? Well Grace is defined like this.
The undeserved and unearned favor and love of
God.
undeserved unearned favor and love of God
It's a gift.
I found this definition. Maybe this illustration will help.
When a person Works an eight-hour day and receives a
day's pay for his time, that's a
wage.
When a person completes competes with an opponent and
receives a trophy for his performance, that is a
prize.
When a person receives appropriate recognition for his long
service or high achievements, that is an award.
But when a person is not capable of earning a wage
can win no prize and deserves No
Award yet receive such a
gift anyway.
That's a good picture of God's unmerited favor.
That is what we mean when we talk about the grace of God.
But just think about that man, don't we?
Default into those first few options really quickly,
right?
Like the wage and the prize and like we we default
into that so quickly where we think
like, you know, I got to earn God's love somehow or or
we need to to try to beat out other people. So we
get up the ladder or or somehow. I
deserve God's love.
No.
Grace is a gift.
And how does that gift?
change everything
look at verses 11 through 14. This is how that
Grace in Jesus changes everything.
For the grace of God has appeared bringing salvation
for all people training us
to renounce ungodliness and worldly passions and
to live self-controlled upright and godly
lives in this present age.
Waiting for our blessed hope the appearing of
the glory of our great God and Savior Jesus Christ who gave
himself for us to redeem us
from all lawlessness and to purify for
himself a people for his own possession who
are zealous for good works.
Now you see there's so much packed into those few
verses.
Just full of gospel.
but notice what it specifically says Jesus coming
did
The grace of God Jesus appeared. What did
he come to do first? He saves us.
He came to save us.
The grace of God has appeared bringing salvation for
all people.
now at first glance
that sounds Universalist, right?
That all people are going to be saved. He came to
save everybody. So everybody's going to make it in but that can't be right
because that goes against so many other scriptures. Say
the opposite.
So what does this mean?
Well, it means the first that jesus' life death and Resurrection is the
means by which people can be saved that
without him. There is no salvation Acts 4:12
says
so he is the way to salvation but also his life
death and Resurrection is effective for all
who will be saved.
He will save people.
He's able.
But there's also this emphasis Paul is giving here that
this salvation was not merely for the Jews.
It was actually for all people groups.
Even remember Romans 1:16. Paul says I'm not ashamed of
the Gospel. It's the power of God for the Salvation of those who believe
First for the Jew but also for the Gentile.
It's for all people. This gospel is not reserved for
one group, but you think about that verse
what's the kicker in that verse the kickers belief?
Belief, that's how a person responds to
Jesus. That is what means salvation or
not.
Ephesians 2 says that by Grace you've been saved through
faith.
And even this is not your own doing it's a gift of God not
a result of work so that no one may boast. So even belief in
faith is still not your work. It's God's
gift.
You might remember it this way that means you are a receiver
of God's grace. Not an
achiever of God's grace.
Nothing. It's a gift. There's nothing in you.
It's simply his.
unmerited favor
But all that begs the question in a group this size.
Have you received that gift?
Have you received his grace? Do you
believe in your heart?
That Jesus died for your sins and God raised him from
the dead.
And do you confess with your mouth and with your life that
Jesus is your lord and your savior?
If you do that means you will be
saved Romans 10 says
like you have been changed.
But don't miss this.
You can grow up in church your entire life.
You can even be a decent human being.
And not have received this gracious salvation of
Jesus.
When Jesus says it in Matthew chapter 7 he's saying
at the very end of time. There's going to be people who walk up to him and say
Lord.
Did we not do amazing things in your name? Did we not look religious?
Did we not live a life that sure seemed like we
were Christians and he's gonna say away from
me. I never knew you.
Like you can even be very religious.
And not be transformed by
the Lord.
So, do you know him?
Do you know this Jesus as your
king and as your savior?
Or maybe the better question is does he know you?
Where you have received this Redemption verse
14 says Redemption from all lawlessness. Have
you been redeemed?
and if not
See who he is today turn from your sin and
yourself and turn to him give your life to him
because he changes everything.
He makes you new.
But here's what we miss communicate about salvation so
often.
What will often talk about it being is is
merely fire Insurance to keep you out of hell when you die.
That salvation is merely about eternity.
Like do you know where you're going to go when you die, right? That's
all that it's about. But the point of this for the grace of
God has appeared bringing salvation for all people. Yes, but look
at the next words in verse 12. He says training us.
Not just about eternity. He's training us
that means in daily life.
He trains us.
So he saves us.
And he trains us.
And just think a good father.
Doesn't have a child and then says to them you're on
your own.
Like I hope you figured out kid. No a good
father trains his children how to live
a Godly life.
It's what God does with us but notice
in verse 12. There's a couple different ways that God
trains us.
verse 12 training us
to renounce ungodliness and worldly passions
and to live self-controlled upright
and godly lives in the present age.
So there's two ways he trains us it says.
First he trains Us by subtraction.
A middle schoolers. We're not going to do a lot of math today, but there
is subtraction. In addition today. Just know that's coming.
But it says he trains us to renounce
that's to remove to give
up to take out of something to renounce
what ungodliness and worldly passion.
Is there anything that goes against God's standard God's ways
anything that that our desires are misaligned
or misdirected. Those are
sinful.
He says we need to subtract those things because
what happens in God's grace clearly God's grace
appeared training us. He leads us
to refuse those things to begin
to deny the power that they have in our
lives.
We sang it earlier but to do what first Thessalonians 1:9 puts
it to turn from Idols to serve
the living and true God.
I love how Ray ortland put this this process. He described
it where he said that our hearts are like
a boardroom.
So imagine a boardroom and you know, the Executive Suite of
some office space and there's a big big long table
in the middle and big leather chairs around it. You got water
bottles in the middle got a big whiteboard over here, right the boardroom where
the decisions are made. That's your heart.
And there's this committee that sits around that table.
A committee of selfs. You might say
And it's the social self. This is
all in your heart the social self the private self the
work self the sexual self the recreational
self the religious self and all kinds
of others, right?
And that Committee of selves is in your heart
is constantly debating and arguing and voting
rarely coming to a wholehearted unanimous
decision, right?
You know what? I'm talking about, you feel that it's just like constant. That's
why we're so unfocused. We're so hesitant. We're
wishy-washy on stuff. We're unfree in
the way. We live.
Now that kind of person.
Can accept Jesus let's just
use that phrase can accept Jesus one of two ways.
One way is to invite Jesus onto the committee.
To give him one vote.
On the committee.
But then all he becomes is just one more voice in
the chaos of the committee.
And he might get drowned out by whichever one is talking the
loudest at that moment.
Okay.
So here's the other way to accept Jesus.
To say this to him.
Jesus my life is not working.
This is not working. So please come
in and fire my committee every single one
of them.
Right to say invite him in and say I'm handing
myself over to you. This whole thing
is your responsibility now, I give my life to
you. You make all the decisions.
See, that's what we mean when we talk about about salvation around
here no matter what you heard before no matter
what I heard when I was growing up when we talk about getting saved. It's
not about adding Jesus to
your life.
It's it's making an acknowledging the
fact that Jesus is the Lord and then subtracting all
the false gods from your life as well.
So many professing Christians have never let go of
their lives to Jesus.
We've merely added him in as one option as one voice
on our committee and saying maybe he's going
to win out this time.
Or we put him as one of the the tools we have on
the shelf, and we pull them down when we need him, but the rest
of our life we're in charge.
You can say all the religious language you want
about Jesus being Savior and Lord if
he is not actually Lord of all,
he's not Lord at all.
So open your hands.
Give up control.
Stop trying to to debate and argue. Just
give him your life because when you open your hands up,
let him remove all the idols in your
life. If you if you're like this you can't do that.
He needs this so he can subtract.
as he needs to
thankfully doesn't only subtract.
It also said in Grace he also trains Us by
addition.
So he trained us to renounce.
Sinful selfish ways,
but then he also trains us verse 12 to
live self-controlled upright Godly
lives.
As we open our hands and submit to him. He trains us
to produce an uprightness in
us where we live like he wants us to his
just righteous standard.
That he gives us what we said the last few weeks new self-control
that it's his control in us
and we've submitted to him and he gives us this new
way of living what he says here a Godly
life.
Where you live more like Jesus lived while he
was on the earth what he wants you to live like in every
area of life.
Godliness seeps down into everything marriage
business Civic responsibilities finances
neighbors. We're going to talk a lot more about
that next week.
what this looks like in daily life, but
but again the point here today.
Is that salvation is not only about what happens
after you die.
He brings salvation, but it's not only about that.
He says the gospel is also good news for this
present age verse 12 said
for today God's grace changes everything today, too.
But here's the problem with that present age.
It's a mess it.
We talk about it being transformed but it's it's broken.
Jesus said it in John 16:33 in this world. You
will have tribulation.
So what's he talking about? Like what kind of tribulation Jesus
well, he's talking about pain in your life first from just
life in general from things. You can't control.
You have pain in life from cancer from early death
of a friend or storms or
floods.
Terrorists earthquakes we saw this week.
It's just pain from life.
You had nothing to do with it.
But there's also pain.
from your own sins consequences
where you are forgiven, eternally,
but you might have to pay the
price here.
You might have to go to jail. You might have to rebuild trust with
your kids. You might have like you can see there's there's ways that
you're going to have to count that as part of
the deal.
From your own decision your own choice.
But there's also pain that comes from persecution many
of our brothers and sisters around the world right now are experiencing that
we may someday.
There's pain in life. There's tribulation.
And so here's another way that God's
grace changes. Everything is that he
sustains us while we wait for the
Blessed. Hope verse 13 says of his second appearing.
He saves us he trains us and he sustains us
until that day comes.
And listen if the world needs anything right now, it could use a
dose of Hope, right?
I mean so much misery.
There's so much pain and depression and
and woe is me mentality. There's
all kinds of hopelessness people watch the
news and have this despair everything. Just getting worse. It's so
bad.
Don't miss out on what the grace of God brings.
Did you see it?
In Titus 2 right his first appearing the grace of God appeared
past tense as Jesus coming the first time he
brought what salvation training he
brought all these things Titus to talks about.
But then it's pointing us to a second appearing.
That his second appearing at the end will consummate the
hope that we have had all along.
But we misunderstand hope too.
We need to get the definition of Grace. What about hope?
See, we don't just hope something will happen.
We hope because we know something will happen.
But you see the difference there.
That we don't just hope man. I hope we win the game tonight. Like
that's that's a hope that you don't know. This is a hope because
we already know it's going to happen.
It's a whole different ballgame.
See listen, our hope is not in circumstances improving because they
might not
Our Hope cannot be in the government turning back to God because it
probably won't
Our hope is not in being wealthy and successful because we
might not ever be that our hope is in the fact that
our great God and savior is coming back one day
to remake this whole thing into a perfect
world forever.
That's our hope that is already settled that
there's a new heavens and new earth coming where we're going to
live with him forever. And that's guaranteed because he resurrected on
the third day.
It's a hope that First Peter 1 describes as a
Living Hope.
What one of our values at church life-giving hope this is
where this comes from First Peter 1 3 through 9 blessed be
the God and father of our Lord Jesus Christ. Who according
to his great Mercy has caused
us to be born again to a Living Hope.
Through the resurrection of Jesus Christ from the dead.
Two an inheritance that is imperishable undefiled
unfading kept in heaven for
you.
Who by God's power are being guarded through
faith for a Salvation ready to be revealed in
the last time.
in this you rejoice
though now for a little while you have been grieved by
various trials.
So that the tested genuineness of your faith more precious
than gold that perishes those tested by
fire.
That Faith may be found to result in praise and
glory and honor at the Revelation the second appearing
of Jesus Christ.
Though you have not seen him. This is talking to us though.
You've not seen him you love him.
Though you do not now see him you believe in him
and rejoice with joy that is inexpressible filled
with Glory obtaining the outcome of
your faith the salvation of your souls.
This is waiting that is filled
with hope filled with
worship filled with joy, even
through the tears of grief from living in
a fallen world. This is saying man. There's something better coming.
And I know it's coming. I know it's going to happen.
Because we can take our notice Jesus even though
he said in John 16, we have trouble in the world in the
same breath. He said yes, but you can have peace in this
same world.
Remember why?
Because I have overcome this
world.
Yeah, it's gonna be hard. Yeah, there's gonna be a lot of tears, but you can
have peace in this because I already beat it all.
And I'm coming back one day.
see listened that is how
That that hope is how a young Widow and
her children.
can face the hardest moment of their
life the death of her husband their father and face
it with
courage face it with joy
Through the tears through the loneliness absolutely that's there,
but they can see a future in God's word.
They can see a future in prayer in community. They can
see a future another Believers through reflecting on this gospel
message. And that change is not only the fact
that they're going to be with him someday the fact that that changes today.
and listen, that is the kind of Life Giving
hope that this is talking about
and I'll tell you right now.
There is nothing in my life that has ever been building my faith like that
watching that happen.
It has filled my soul with such joy and in depth
watching that.
This is Hope.
that the world needs
but what do we do until that day?
What do we do until Jesus returns? I mean, he's
he's promised. Yes. He's coming back. We know it's sure but what do we
do until then?
Do we just sit on the couch? Lazil eating popcorn watching
the world burn around us. Is that what we're supposed to do?
Like we're gonna get out of this thing pretty soon. So look forward to
that day. You guys are in trouble like no now, that's not right.
What do we do?
God's grace changes everything eternally. Yes, but notice in
verse 14. He did all of this to purify for
himself a people for his own possession
who are zealous for good works.
You ever seen your dog the way they react when you say let's
go for a walk.
Start shaking God can't do anything but
just focus so much on that excited. Zealous is
the word.
A people for his own possession who are zealous for
good works.
To be like that for what he wants
us to do.
But we must be it says in verse 14 purified. So
so he saves us he trains us he sustains
us and he purifies us every
day now until that day comes
he is refining purifying now. We're
talking a lot more about good works next week in chapter 3 what all
that means but now no what he's talking about here is zealous
for those things are the things that you do to live
like Jesus.
Like what would Jesus do that whole bracelet thing? Right?
What would he do? How would he be? How would he live?
That's what we saw earlier uprightness godliness with an
eye to Eternity. It's living like he would.
Second Peter 3 says that what sort of people ought
you to be in lives of Holiness and godliness today waiting for
and hastening the coming of the day of God meaning something changes today
as you wait.
I want to take you in a little bit of a journey here. This is so important.
Because that word purifying verse 14 means to cleanse we
sing about it earlier that we were in our sin Crimson
stained we could do nothing about it. But but the
cleansing blood of Jesus washed us
made us white as snow.
And I want you to remember something that that's
how you are spiritually right now
before the Throne of God.
Not you earning that.
But if you are in Jesus who is perfect
who stands righteous, who is
your Advocate your substitute if you're in him
you're standing there pure.
That's the the reality of the Redemption
of the blood of Jesus that he has made us. Holy
in him that we are his very own.
I want you to remember that Christian because that is your identity now.
The world says so much else the enemy will throw something
in your mind and say no. No, that's not you. Look at what you did
yesterday. Look at what you did 10 years ago. You're not clean. You're
not pure God doesn't love you.
this
Is who you are Christian?
Second Peter 1 3 and 4 his divine power has granted to
us all things that pertain to life and godliness through
the knowledge of him who called us to his own glory and
Excellence by which Jesus he has granted to
us his precious and very great promises. So
that through them you may become partakers of
the divine nature.
Through those things you are now partakers of
the divine nature having escaped from the
corruption that is in the world because of sinful desire.
Did you see those are all past tense indicatives? Those are
all things that have already happened?
He called you. He saved you he made you different.
He made you a partaker you've escaped from
right? That's all past tense.
That means that's who you already are. Don't forget.
That's who you are.
Starts there. It's only there and so that definition
means we must then move
forward from that. We don't start anywhere else we start
there. That's who we are the process we're talking about. Now. This
purification is talking about big word
sanctification.
It's how he has made us something eternally
and one day we'll be back there glorified with him bodily. But
for now, he's making us more
like we already are.
See what I mean by that we're already there.
It's spiritually we are standing there pure 100%
Now he's making us more into that every day
second Peter 1 continues for this very reason.
Meaning because God's done all of that.
make every effort to supplement your faith with virtue virtue
with knowledge knowledge with self-control self-control with
steadfastness steadfasted with godliness godliness with
brotherly affection brotherly affection with love all
of these daily character qualities, see that
For if these qualities are yours and are increasing.
They keep you from being ineffective or unfruitful in
the knowledge of our Lord Jesus Christ.
What he's saying there?
You've already been set free so live as
if you are free.
You're already free from the corruption of your sinful nature.
Now, it's still we get it the flesh. There's all that but
but effectively live it out that you
already are.
Just live out who you already are in Christ.
Just think about it for a
freed prisoner.
To go back into the jail cell and chain themselves
back up. That's pretty silly, isn't it?
It's called spiritual amnesia.
You forget what you've been freed from.
That's what verse 9 even says as he continues for
whoever lacks. These qualities is so nearsighted. He's
blind having forgotten that he was cleansed
from his former sins.
You've been freed.
Don't go back and chain yourself up over it.
But here's the key.
Here's the key remembering.
And Awakening to this eternity-changing
life-changing grace of God in Jesus.
That's the only way you will consistently make
progress in your spiritual life.
remembering
and Awakening to the grace of
God is the only way you're going to make progress in
your spiritual life.
Not by trying harder not by doing more
things or going to church more doing this more that more. It's
not about that. We must consistently Delight in
and be thrilled by this great good
news of Jesus.
And that's why you get the constant drumbeat of it here and like
what if you've been here for any length of time, you're like man, they
say the same thing over and over and over again. Yeah, that's why.
Because this is our source.
This is our treasure the gospel. Jesus life.
Death and Resurrection is our treasure.
And here's what it does. It keeps us two ways. It
keeps us from being downcast over our sin.
And it keeps us from being arrogant over our salvation.
Because if it's Grace remember Grace is a gift
if it's Grace, then you didn't deserve it. So don't
get arrogant about it.
And if it's Grace that's undeserved. It means that that
is covered.
Whatever. That was whatever that is, it's covered.
Think first John 3:1.
see what kind of love
father has given to us that we
should be called children of God.
And so we are.
That changes everything right?
That God would choose to make
us his children.
stunning
So what is our response to that look like?
Our response should not immediately. Go back to those first couple options instead
of Grace. It should not merely be towards well effort and
Purity and Holiness and obedience. Like I got to
try harder I got to do this more. No, our Pursuit should be toward
Christ himself.
It should be towards him. He is the source he is
Grace.
He is the one we should pursue because listen, there
is no power toward change as powerful
as an awe and an affection
for the king of kings.
There's nothing that will compare to that kind of
power.
I could use so many examples here and this really does relate to every
single area of Our Lives Temptation wise, but I want to pick one. That's
very tangibly relevant.
Here's an example if if we want our kids to remain
sexually pure until marriage.
It's not enough to Simply. Tell them the consequences
if they don't.
That's not strong enough.
It won't last.
What they need is Not Mere risk avoidance.
Because the brain don't even work right yet until make
those decisions, right? They don't need mere risk avoidance. They
need to be fully awakened to the glories of
the Gospel in Jesus Christ.
All of Christ is far stronger than
any risk of avoidance. Yes, we should
warn of the risk. Yes. We should celebrate the benefits of waiting. But
did you see in Titus 2 what God
has done.
I mean look at he's bought us he's saved us
he's training us. He's sustaining us even Ephesians
5 about marriage says Jesus died for
us to sanctify us to cleanse us
with the word to present us to himself in splendor
without spot or wrinkle that we might be holy that
we might be without blemish. This is what he's
done for us.
And why do we do it?
So that we could be his very own.
So that we can be his.
That's a way more compelling reason to walk in holiness.
students listen
You're going to told your entire life.
That this is what you should do shouldn't do I want you to see that
you are his.
You are his and that gives you privilege and
power and things that you could never do
on your own the ability to overcome Temptation. You can never do
on your own.
And there is hope.
When you fail that you can't have on your own.
But that is the hope we're talking about that is way more
compelling for any of you adults as well like this. No matter
what Temptation you face the way more compelling way to fight
that is by Jesus being that much better than anything
you face.
I want to choose him. I don't want that.
I don't choose him. He's better. He's the treasure.
But you can only get there if you don't forget who you are.
Christian you have to remember who you are who
God made you to be in Jesus?
Some of you might remember a few years ago. We went through the Book of Judges.
And the series was called identity crisis.
Because there's so many things going on about telling us who we are and we
needed to remember.
Who he says we are.
And our key passage was first Peter 2 verses 9
and 10 and reminds us even today of who
we are in him Church.
that you
Are a chosen race?
You are a royal priesthood.
a holy nation
a people
for his own possession
so that
you may proclaim the excellencies.
Of him who called you out of the darkness
you were in into His Marvelous Light.
before
you were not a people.
but now
you are God's people.
Before you had not received Mercy.
but now
you have received Mercy.
God's grace changes everything
so let's live more like that is true
every day.
God I
come to you we come to you and we just need you.
desperately
We thank you for your word.
Church, just as we reflect now for a
moment, maybe.
maybe what God is
prompting you to do and this is just an illustration physically is to open
your hands before him.
Let invite you do that if you want to if not, that's fine. But but just
as an illustration maybe in your own heart of where you need
to open up your hands where you've been clinging tightly and
you say Jesus. I need you to run this thing.
and you just physically right now before you open your
own hands as an
Example of what your heart is saying to him?
And just to physically in your heart let go.
of
the idols to let go of the control to let go of
even the past
God as we do this right now we
I feel knowing that.
There's someone in this room who's who's got
the barriers up the walls up?
And they can't open their hands to you. God break through
that right now.
whether it's a sin issue or
A relational issue or a past struggle
or or some doubt? They have God opened
their heart and their eyes right now so they can open their hands to
you.
God don't let us try to take control with any
of those selves inside of us. May you take over.
Break us where we need it God. There's so much
we hold on to so much that we are resistant to.
May we see you from your word as worth it.
What you've done?
To make us your own.
How can we not sing your excellencies sing
your Praises? How can we not live in a way that's free
because you've already made us free. How can we not how how
can we not
Take hold of what you've given us.
And be changed completely for it.
But God that's got to be your work.
Pray for your work in each life here today.
to comfort The Afflicted
to challenge the lazy
to sustain us as we look ahead to the
day when we have no more pain or tears.
God open our eyes our hearts.
in our hands
to respond to you.
Maybe you've never done that before.
Maybe you're seeing all this and you're like, I don't know anything what you're
talking about. Listen, there's
there's a simple confession to the Lord today in your
heart that he is.
Your savior because you're a sinner.
And you say Jesus your lord?
Come talk to one of us after.
Come find me during the songs. I don't
care. That's fine.
But just to deal with this and say Jesus, I'm Yours.
And we jump so quickly to singing or to whatever else is
next Even in our lives.
Just sit with this let the Lord work in your
heart.
And maybe it means you don't stand up when we start to sing. Maybe it means
you get on your knees or you you take a step of faith
in some other way to respond. That's all worship is it's not just singing It's worship
is response.
To what God's doing?
We are going to sing to him for what he's done.
but let it be out of a heart of
response